here with reaction florida senator marco
rubio you're on the intel community
senator i read uh i went back and looked
at a lot of your tweets you had you
warned them this would fail you told
them exactly what would happen they
ignored everything that you told them uh
and others and the next step is you
predict this will now once again be a
safe haven for poor groups like al qaeda
moving forward
yeah sean not just did i tell them but
there was a bipartisan warning okay
you look at the intelligence you look at
everything before us it was clear that
not now it was the worst case scenario
out there it was the likeliest outcome
that was going to happen and we kept
insisting what is the plan of this
happens what is the plan and they
arrogantly and they smugly ignored it
they ignored everyone who was warning
them because they're the experts they
know everything and now we've seen the
consequences there are two things now to
keep in mind number one is joe biden was
elected promising competence to return a
normalcy the return of expertise to
foreign policy and we see that they
can't even execute on something like
this and ignore the people who know
something about it that does encourage
people like china countries like china
and other adversaries not just to go out
and try to undermine confidence in
america but actually test america and
think they can get away with it and the
other is something that the pentagon's
already saying and we've already been
saying for close to nine months the
biggest problem here is going to be now
that al qaeda is coming back to have to
to afghanistan let there be no doubt
they are coming back they will
reconstitute they will pose a threat
again and this administration has no
plan whatsoever to prevent that from
happening china's involved sorry russia
is involved in cyber attacks against
this country then they get a waiver for
a pipeline and they get a summit with
joe biden
china is threatening our military bases
they're threatening japan's military
bases they're threatening to take over
an independent sovereign country taiwan
they're calling it reunification and
they're lecturing america on human
rights in anchorage and are ever
pathetically weak secretary of state as
allowing them to do so with no pushback
so my question is why wouldn't the
chinese think that they can take or
reunify their term with taiwan
foreign policy is a very tough business
and a lot of it is not made i know it's
not made in the parlors of the capitals
of the cities it's not made in these
think tanks it's not made by the
commentary class it is hard-nosed
nation-states making a decision what can
we get away with and if we do this with
this what's going to happen to us and
right now with joe biden in the white
house our adversaries are going to
conclude that there are things they can
get away with and they can do because
this white house is not strong they're
not prepared they're not even competent
and i fear what that means there's a big
big problem isn't it it wasn't the
difference we're going to compare i know
some people were so offended and you
know their daily outrage at donald
trump's tweeting but um donald trump was
able to get trade deals that nobody
thought possible because everybody
believed that a trade war would come and
that he would follow through
our enemies knew and for example look at
isis he defeated the caliphate you know
biden obama weren't capable of dealing
with any such threat they don't seem to
have
there's no belief that joe biden will
lift a finger to stop anything here
which means these nations their
geopolitical geographical ambitions are
going to be pursued and likely they will
be successful
yeah look the war in afghanistan had to
come to a conclusion this couldn't go on
forever but it had to be done the right
way not this way and what this way
reveals is you can get away with things
with this administration and they're not
going to take it seriously they're not
going to know what to do about it and i
look back at the soleimani strike and it
was widely condemned it was called
murder and execution all kinds of people
attacking president trump for doing it i
assure you i assure you a hundred
percent i know for a fact that it
impacted the psychology of the iranian
regime and and of the group that solemni
headed it had a name but they feared
trump they feared him and they believed
he was capable of following through on
his threats that's number one well and
unfortunately that's exactly what a lot
about foreign policy is all about is
what do your adversaries believe they
can get away with now what you're saying
not what you're writing what do they
think you will do and the sole of money
strikes sent the message it was
important to do the guy was a smug guy
that would walk around fly around with
impunity he thought he was untouchable
until he wasn't and it had an impact
there's no fear of that happening under
joe biden none but the trump plan was
based on conditions on the ground and a
genuine fear
that like donald trump wiped out the
caliphate that they would be the taliban
would be wiped out similarly if they
dare to try this if donald trump was
president this didn't happen on trump's
watch this happened on biden's watch
while biden was on vacation and couldn't
bother to even take time to deal with it
because they they operated under
assumptions that were completely
ridiculous the assumption was well what
if the afghans stand up and fight and
really push back if you make those
assumptions yeah they could have held on
for another six months or a year but all
the indications were that as soon as the
u.s announced they were leaving police
officers would abandon post the regular
armed forces would abandon post and
leaders would abandon the country that
is exactly what happened is what they
were told that's what they were warned
what happened they didn't care and now
we see the consequences of it all right
senator thank you for being with us